Wayne Rooney has to go here wait it's
going to bro I promise you we're going
to have some issues rude
vanro Wayne Rooney has to be right here
where's there's loads of honorary
mentions where's Van Persie there's no
TW what are you talking about don't you
dare put van pers in the greatest the
great you mention just because you hate
Arsenal so much it's not about Arsenal
it's about Robin van pers coming and
winning us the league doesn't matter
single-handedly over like canana Rooney
needs to be up here as well by way
that's the last League title we've ever
won he is not getting on this I'm just
saying let's respect him yeah you said
it now we can move on and Dwight y
there's a lot of guy listen Andy Cole
yeah yeah he's my heroing him out we're
going to have to push you boys on a
decision so what are you doing he's
playing it's because here we got a big
problem this is the whole this we deal
that later all right all right all right
all right yes yes yes yes yes right
let's lock those two names in please
there we go Rooney and can that was hard
man